[Music]
what's up sarah
hi how's it going today good how are you
oh you know just trying to beat this
missouri heat
yes
it's just hot the whole country is hot
hot yes exactly
so what's up
um well i am hoping you can help me
um show empathy to mainly my husband and
family and really be a fun wife again
oh man all right tell me more
so my husband and i have been married
seven years this coming fall we have two
toddlers who are
three and one and a half so obviously a
lot has changed in the last three and a
half years this pregnancy and two small
children coming
coming into our world and you know my
husband just tells me i'm not fun joyful
why city married
i'm mean and grouchy and you know
frankly i feel like that some of the
time okay so um he's not here to defend
himself and so i'm just going to talk to
you okay
yep are you mean and grouchy
yeah sometimes i am mean and grouchy yes
you're hedging your bet um that means
sometimes you're super fun and playful
and exciting
yep sometimes
uh like on the weekends right and then
during the week it's like business right
like we got the routine with the kids
it's hard for me to break routine it's
um it's this balance now that we have
two toddlers and not babies as this
balance of when to say yes and when to
say no and when to give in to my crying
toddler and when to hold the boundary
right and so that's
um
lucky for you all the internet uh
information is exactly the same it all
just tells you what to do
that's so stupid
um okay so
who were you before these toddlers
ruined everything
um
well we recently started counseling and
i feel i know a lot of help right is
helping
um and i feel like some of the
uh
bringing up the you know the i would say
try it's not really trauma but um the
ordeal this is why situation i was given
as a child is now coming up more so
um so my dad passed away when i was a
kid and i grew up with a stepdad who
pretty much gasped lit me my whole life
i never really had a voice in my house
um
and i didn't ever find my voice and so i
overcompensated to try and fix
everything and i'm apologetic
and so
and hold on
you're you apologize and try to fix
everything
you try to make sure everybody else is
okay
yep
some of that may come from your
gaslighting stepdad how old were you
when your dad died
uh two okay
came in at four and a half five okay
my guess and dude i could be way out to
lunch we had to lunch two and three and
four there's some pretty formative years
there
um
may have been more around the emotional
regulation of your mom
yeah okay
um
you could probably learn at a really
young age if i do this mom
shuts down
mom dealing with dads the dad's your
dad's passing his grief right
um is a lot
all that to say is this um
we
you have a tether from the past to the
present
yep bring me back here
um
yeah so
i think every time i i mean heck i'm
doing it right now every time i try and
have a hard conversation i start to cry
it's like my instant reaction
um a bad thing it's not a bad thing no
it just sometimes drives my husband nuts
because he's like we're just having a
conversation why are you crying and it's
like
i can't control it my body just reacts
this way right and then i start to
apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry i'm crying i'm sorry that i'm
doing this i don't want to be doing this
you know and i'm trying to fix it
gotcha and so let me tell you this
you're not broken
you you don't you don't need to be fixed
okay
okay your tears are a signal
they're a gift they're letting you know
something about you that you care about
something that's all your husband needs
to kind of get over that
okay got to move on and this is the pot
talking to the kiddo because her to my
wife would cry be like what i do
whatever and she finally was like it's
not about you the whole world's not
about you every thought in my head and
everything my body doesn't know about
you and i was like oh well played okay
yeah you're not broken
good for you for being a person that
still feels
oh thank you it's awesome it's good
okay you're not broken
okay so
um
who were you before these toddlers
ruined everything
i mean i think i well i think my job has
a lot to do with it i got a new job also
four years ago so let's just throw that
into the mix might as well
um okay let me back up i want to follow
thread i want to make sure i don't lose
this yep were you fun and crazy and
super girlfriend and super fun wife
as a way of
making sure your husband stuck around
no i don't think so i think i was just
more relaxed
i think i just didn't
i was a bit in a sense like things just
i didn't hold as much anxiety or if we
do this i'm gonna ruin the kids you know
i'm gonna you know i i'm more structured
now which is probably difficult um and i
think i'm
[Music]
i
i'm just
really struggling to find the balance of
like
when to just say screw bedtime we're
gonna you know we're gonna go to a park
on a wednesday night and if the kids go
to bed late who cares
you know even though we have to work on
thursday morning right um
if my husband says hey let's go to the
park and then you know it's i'm looking
at the clock being like at 6 30. our
kids go to bed at seven like does that
make sense you know like okay hold on
there's so much here
um okay i'm gonna just dive right in you
tell me when to shut up okay okay so um
the reason i asked you and your answer
i'm so glad you gave that answer um i
wanted to see if that the emotional
regulation of your mom the gaslighting
if that kind of stuff had you were
playing a role as the super fun person
we all have friends who
played a role at the party they drank a
couple more drinks they were a little
bit louder they made out with a few more
people like because that was the role
they were assigned in whatever group
they were in right now you're telling me
that that was definitely not my role i
was the girl like driving everybody home
and staying responsible okay so you're
okay and then you met a guy that you
loved and you could anchor into
yes and by anchoring in for the first
time probably in your life
because your dad passed away when you're
young your mom struggled with that grief
and then your stepdad came in and made
you the reason all his life sucked and
then you felt met this guy and you could
finally go whoo
right
you're hitting the nail on the head john
and then
two things happen
um
the moment you have that first baby
your body has a pen in that and it
remembers
that somebody goes away
okay
yep
somebody's gonna go away
and you're looking at that little baby
and you're conjuring up story after
story after story about who's gonna go
away and when and why
and then as the person who drives
everybody home from the party you start
creating lists and objectives and
things and you're gonna feed that
anxiety you're gonna solve that anxiety
with more data but you're end up feeding
it because you're gonna get some more
information you're gonna do this and it
and it becomes an exercise in i'm gonna
control every freaking variable so
somebody doesn't go away again is that
fair
wow yes that is completely fair and then
it gets more fun
um
you start grabbing the steering wheel so
tight that the circulation gets cut off
in your hands and you don't even know
the hell you are anymore and the people
around you don't know who you are
anymore and what you do know is your
hands are so tight on that wheel that
you can't reach over and hug that kid
and you can't reach over and grab your
husband by the back of the neck and give
him one of those weird crazy kisses he
used to give him
fair
yes and most importantly
you can't let go of that thing and look
in the mirror and say how's sarah doing
and so here's what i want to tell you
okay
somebody's probably not going away
and so there's a moment when you have to
make peace with your body who's trying
to love you and remember the worst
trauma ever
and say thank
you um but we're good now
we're good now
okay and then you've got a three and a
one year old which is just a shake in
the snow globe i mean it's not it's it's
it's not
a hundred percent of i'd have never met
in my life
a couple who's like i got a three and we
have a three year old and a one year old
and our sex life is insane i've never
met that couple ever yeah a hundred
percent of couples with a three and a
one year old are like i don't know what
day it is i don't even like my husband
he's disgusting and my wife's weird and
she's gotten me i've never i've never
met that couple it's not like that so
you've heard me say this a million times
and i'll say it a million more times
okay
the fun exciting curious adventure to go
on now
is not
anymore
it's not how can we get back to
and that's some language i know he's not
here to defend himself that language has
to go away because anymore
is gone
yeah
pre through two kids
yeah sarah doesn't exist she's a myth
she doesn't exist like she's back there
and by the way pre-two kid's husband
is isn't exist anymore
yeah and so the only question we have is
are there's two questions how can we
drag the past into the future and it's
gonna be a copy of a copy of a copy a
fifth rate
b team jv version of what was
it's gonna be a weird weekend where you
have five drinks so you can become crazy
sarah again and he's gonna get a half
fun half weirded out half tired half
grouchy you know what i'm saying it's
just a copy of a copy and
that's you right now right or yeah
or
y'all are going to build something
totally freaking new
and say now we have two little kids
we've brought into this thing and i
still want to be fun crazy reckless sexy
sarah
it's just gonna have to be after bedtime
which means i'm gonna work on texting
you in the day and getting you fired up
and i'm gonna work on wearing something
different if that's something that
you're gonna talk about and you are
gonna work on helping with bedtime
because that's the hottest thing you can
do right now right yeah or you're gonna
have to cut your gym short
you can't work out for an hour and a
half you've got to do it for an hour now
because i need those 30 minutes you're
helping with the dishes washing the
bottles whatever the thing is in your
home it is let's create something new
and we're going to create it for this
season
and then that three and the one-year-old
i'm telling you you're about to get
magic corner you get about three years
away from magic when both of those kids
can bathe themselves
and then dude and then go to the
bathroom by themselves
it's like a whole other planet opens up
right and then you're gonna recreate it
then and then we're gonna recreate it a
little bit later and then we're gonna
recreate it a little bit you know i mean
so
the exercise and the excitement and the
fun is now
let's create something magic and let's
just live into it and the living into it
is fun right we get to do cool stuff
it's that intentionality not not the way
things were is that fair
that's yeah that's completely fair and
for i've i've not met any couples who
that doesn't become a cool adventure
yeah because then he gets to say here's
what i need
and you get to say here's what i need
and then it's like oh sweet i can make
that happen
you mean all this happens if i just do
those things and then you think the same
thing and then dude now we're in magic
yeah that makes sense
that makes sense and let me tell you one
more thing
my wife told me this and it was a really
important moment it's about budgeting
um we would come up with a budget and we
would like we want to have these
financial goals we'd really have a
budget have a budget have a budget and
then we'd get about three weeks in and
we had the last week of the month and
then i'd come home from work really
tired and i would say let's just go out
and eat and i would name some fancy
restaurant
and she'd be like hey it's not in the
thing and i'd be like i know dude it's
the last week let's just go dude we
could this and this and this
and she i did this for years
and then she told me one day
you are using me
you are making it my responsibility to
be the bad guy in this budget thing and
that's not fair
we both agreed on x
and now you're turning it around on me
and making it my fault
and so when it comes to things like
bedtime i think routines and bedtime
with kids is really really important
especially three and under
and so letting your husband know every
time you throw that out
you're making me be the bad guy and it's
not fair
it's not cool
does that make sense and usually
he's tired and just wants to go have
some fun with his kids and he doesn't
know what that looks like just playing
with trucks and i don't know what's
happening with a one-year-old just
laying there going
and so let's go to the park it just
sounds like a thing people do on tv
and then he throws it out there and then
you say no and that feeds his story that
my wife just got old and boring
yeah and he throws it out there and that
feeds your story that my husband's
completely unglued un unconnected to
these kids i don't know what's happening
in here why is it you see him saying
then he's become this self-reinforcing
dance
yep so don't have the conversation when
you're upset or when he throws that grin
have it offline in a planning let's
create something new it's his new
adventure hey don't make me the bad guy
on these deals if we agree bedtime's
important bedtime's always going to be
important at least through the first
three years
and then if we want to do a surprise
thing here a surprise thing there
awesome let's go do that let's have some
fun adventures about once a month now
once every two months my daughter just
has the night where she's not sleeping
she's six
and i'll go sit out there and i'll read
she'll color we have a magic time she
sits about an hour and a half later than
normal and she's at peace and then she
goes it's awesome
it's hard to do that with a one-year-old
right occasionally this is hard to do
that with one year old
don't make don't let it make you the bad
guy
so quick recap
your dad passed away and your body's
looking for the next person to leave
especially now that you got these little
ones
probably nobody's going to go
and so when that anxiety comes up when
your body comes up when that idea that i
need to grab control i got to grab
control when it starts coming up
thank your body
say thank you for trying to protect me
but i'm good now
i got a rock
and i'm good good mom
and then y'all just excavate everything
what was
the dating y'all the first couple of
four years with no kids y'all
and now you have a new adventure
a new sexy romantic fun off-kilter
exciting whatever adventure ahead of you
it's also going to have regular bedtimes
for the little ones
and plan it and be specific about it and
then go
get it you're awesome sarah